bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end
l'émission consacrée vous le savez à vos
loisirs et vos idées de sorties alors au
programme des expositions à ne pas rater
la page sport avec du quidditch et oui
mais aussi du cinéma et de la musique
mais tout d'abord place à notre invité
il vient nous présenter une activité
spéciale noël à versailles ou le potager
du roi prépare noël et pour en parler
avec nous d'avis de provo bonjour alors
vous êtes jardinier au potager du roi et
ce samedi 13 13 décembre toute la
journée vous nous réserver quelques
surprises notamment un marché de noël un
peu spécial est ce que pour nous en dire
un petit peu plus oui tout à fait donc
cette année nous allons ouvrir le
premier marché de noël sera organisé sur
le potager du roi et en cette occasion
donc d'à côté de talons ressortir divers
produits comme pas mal de légumes
consoeur de façon assez rares comme la
caf estime tubéreux séparément vie de
foi nous montrer peut-être ces raisons
le crown du japon d'accord donc petit
légume racine un petit goût d'artichaut
à s'étendre à cuisiner nous avons
également la capucine tubéreuse là qu'il
ya un goût remarquable d'accord c'est
devenu rare aujourd'hui vraiment très
très rare et d'ailleurs ces légumes
était ce intéressant pour son côté épicé
donc on a également dit amarillo donc
voilà vraiment proposer quelques légumes
anciens et quelques variétés de légumes
qu'on trouve assez rarement que vous
cultivez donc au jardin tout à fait
voilà que leur accord tout est cultivée
uniquement sur place qu'est-ce que vous
avez ramené d'autres parmi les alors
justement
quelque chose d'assez particulier pour
ce marché de noël qui aura une
dégustation de soupe à base de variétés
comme la bleue de hongrie et la
moulinette jasper de vendée elle me le
net que vous retrouvez ici donc des
soupes qui seront proposés à tous les
visiteurs
donc de ce marché de noël et il sait
également le moment où on va ressortir
quelques confiture qui sont faits par
les jardiniers avec les produits du
potager du roi notamment des confitures
de poires anciennes voilà donc comme
messire jean qui date du 16e
donc en fait vous vous mettrez en vendre
ses légumes assez rare et vous là
pouvait proposer proposera également
sous forme de soupe de confiture et les
habitants auront le choix c'est ça voilà
tout à fait ok allons qui aura le marché
de noël donc avec
des produits mis en vente mais également
une chasse au trésor organisée
tout à fait nous allons en résine chasse
au trésor autour donc de l'agroécologie
la graphologie qu'est ce que c'est pour
les joints l'agroécologie on va dire que
c'est tout et eric alternative pour
cultiver le jardin donc notamment en
utilisant des abris à auxiliaire en
apprenant également de l'enherbement
maîtriser ou alors de la culture sur la
zad qui en fait des déchets végétaux on
cultive directement dessus d'accord donc
une chasse aux trésors de signer plus
aux enfants forcément mais comment ça va
se passer alors c'est une enquête ça se
passe et comment pour ces enfants qui
veulent y participer
alors en fait il va avoir plusieurs
points dans le jardin autour donc d'une
technique en agroécologie donc c'est oui
c'est une forte d'1 kg est donc les
enfants devront résoudre des énigmes et
trouver une lettre et au camp ils vont
tout élec
il ya un mot assemblée s'il y arrive
donc ils ont droit à un cadeau à la fin
très bien le jardin qui sera
exceptionnellement ouvert pour
l'occasion et apparemment que l'hiver
est une période propice justement à
l'observation des arbres fruitiers
c'est bien ça voilà coûtera 11 de tous
les jardins on va dire on retrouve
souvent donc au potager on aura
l'occasion pendant l'hiver parce que
c'est la meilleure période pour voir les
a remises à nu donc toutes les formes
fruitières compte à peu près une
soixantaine de femmes africaines
différentes soixantaine vous êtes un des
plus gros jardin qui on avouera
d'ailleurs un des plus
déjà elle est plus diversifié très bien
quoi d'autre une librairie aussi faire
avec beaucoup de livres
donc sur les germains sur les insectes
également c'est au tour de la cuisine
d'accord autour la cuisine c'est une
première pour quoi cette première cette
année on a décidé voilà deux
des profiter de cette période de noël
donc pour faire un rassemblement autour
du potager c'est vrai que
les gens ont l'habitude de voir le
potager durant le printemps l'été et
l'automne
mais l'hiver est une période
où les gens ne viennent pas forcément je
pense que ce n'est pas très intéressant
non seulement pour découvrir le jardin
mais également découvrir d'ailleurs
certains légumes qui sont toujours
cultivé des divers ça qu'on a
l'impression qu'ils verts n'y a plus
rien à me l'aviez un peu sur les images
le jardin reste est vivant et des
légumes plus encore
voilà il ya encore de l'activité ok
alors le tarif on l'a on n'a pas parlé
donc c'est un euro pas grand chose et
c'est aussi gratuit pour les enfants et
les parents qui participent à la chasse
au trésor c'est bien ça donc je le
répète la journée spéciale noël au
potager du roi à versailles donc c'est
ce samedi de 10h à 17h c'est accessible
à tous
merci david provost on continue avec les
idées de sorties spéciales fêtes de noël
ce samedi toujours de 14 heures à 18
heures vous aurez l'occasion de
confectionner des boules de noël en
origami
ça s'appelle des maths dans mon sapin
s'est ouvert à tous et ça se passe à la
maison de l'environnement de magny les
hameaux
et si vous êtes plutôt gourmand
direction montigny le bretonneux la
librairie du pavé du canal vous invite à
découvrir la sélection de livres et de
coffrets pour confectionner vos biscuits
de noël et à cette occasion toute
l'équipe s'est mise aux fourneaux pour
vous faire goûter ses quelques recettes
rendez vous de 10 heures à 18 heures
allez on parle exposition à présent à la
maison de l'environnement de magny les
hameaux l'exposition matisse hymne vous
propose de vous amuser avec les maths et
ce samedi toute la journée
c'est la dernière occasion d'en profiter
avant que l'exposition ne se
délocalisent
voici une petite piqûre de rappel avec
ce reportage de mélanie poké et william
l
les mathématiques font partie de notre
quotidien
mais le plus souvent ils ignorent où on
ne veut pas le voir au choix
l'exposition matisse hymne proposée par
l'association cap sciences à
l'initiative du conseil général est
présenté en ce moment à la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux
elle fait tomber bien des clichés le
plus connu les maths ça ne sert à rien
c'est faux ça va être retrouvée dans la
maison à l'école en voiture les maths
sont partout et c'est aussi de montrer
comment est-ce qu'on peut approcher les
maths de façon ludique et amusante
l'exposition peut se visiter en accès
libre ou avec des animateurs une partie
réservée aux exercices de logique sur
des tablettes numériques
une autre revient sur les grands
penseurs mathématiques
ici on apprend même à se servir d'un
boulier chinois on est accompagné tout
au long de l'exposition également par
des personnages qui vous explique
justement niveau historique comment elle
est pensée mathématique sont apparus et
puis une dernière partie vraiment de
récréation où là on vous allez avoir
différents jeux comme le tangram
l'épaule idron on va essayer de
concevoir
voilà des petits jeux reproduire un cube
avec des formes géométriques différentes
ce jour là des élèves de 6e du collège
des sols étaient invités à se creuser la
tête
je dois réaliser une pyramide avec
plusieurs sortes de bulma deux comme ça
et de coups comme ça et pas évident je
trouve pas comment faire les formes pour
réaliser des cars et 10 hexagone et des
triangles pas évident et pourtant tout
cela a un sens ça permet également de
s'inscrire dans le cadre
deux programmes scolaires donc de
d'accompagner non seulement les élèves
des écoles mais également ceux des
collèges de voir des lycées à leur
proposant des activités qui illustre
certain nombre de d'aspe des programmes
qu'on leur propose l'exposition qui se
veut très ludique se termine le 13
décembre
elle est ouverte du mardi au samedi est
accessible dès 7 ans et parallèlement
dans cette même thématique la maison de
l'environnement consacre une soirée le 4
décembre
un mathématicien indien du 19e siècle
alors les maths se la faire bien à
quelque chose que les maths ça servait à
beaucoup de choses avant du com compte
pour compter les choses faire des
échanges ou même pour construire des
châteaux par exemple ça servait à
beaucoup de choses avant voisins le
bretonneux a rendu hommage ce week end à
hélène-boucher une aviatrice dont
l'avion s'est écrasé à guyancourt
c'était il ya tout juste 80 ans la vie
le propose une exposition sur ces femmes
pilotes
mélanie poquet éolienne elle qui a dit
que l'aviation était un monde réservé
aux hommes quand on circule dans cette
exposition on se rend compte d'une chose
les femmes aussi ont marqué
l'aéronautique comme on parle beaucoup
d'égalité homme femme
nous avons voulu montrer que dans
l'aéronautique nous avons pas attendu
l'ère moderne pour montrer que les
femmes étaient au moins égale tivement
des hommes
la première salle est spécifiquement
dédié à hélène-boucher l'aviatrice né à
paris en 1908 détient plusieurs records
du monde de vitesse
elle meurt en 1934 à 26 ans lors d'un
vol d'entraînement à guyancourt
la deuxième salle elle est consacrée
plus généralement à ces femmes pilotes
elles sont pionnières de l'aéronautique
elles ont été également militaire elles
ont été vaines yvonne l on fait tous les
métiers de l'aéronautique des pilotes de
chasse des pilotes de planeurs mais
aussi des pilotes aérospatiale comme
claudie haigneré première femme
française à avoir été dans l'espace
ici il y à peu près 200 objets
de l'art au nautic ancienne entre les
années 1930 et 1940 dont deux moteurs
celui sur lequel je suis ici c'est celui
qui équipait le goudron rafale de
l'époque des moteurs donc mais aussi des
tenues des années 90 et des maquettes
parmi les trésors cette photo à
l'original pris par robert doisneau et
le making off prêté par l'entreprise
renault ici comme trésor vous avez une
planche de bord qui est la planche d'un
renaud lucioles de 1937 qui est équipé
avec les équipements les instruments de
bord de l'époque
c'est une pièce originelle original est
déposé et pour ceux qui n'ont jamais pu
prendre les commandes d'un avion mais
qui en rêvent
un passionné a construit son propre
simulateur de vol un travail de six ans
pour tous créé lui-même cet ordinateur
programme des voyages d'une heure où
tout paraît presque réel l'objectif
c'est d'expliquer comment fonctionne un
avion de ligne à monsieur tout le monde
l'objectif étant que
c'est un mystère donc il faut absolument
démystifier cette opération à décoller
c'est très complexe et atterrissant en
plus difficile voit le programme et
check list contrôle et l'avion est paré
au décollage
mais willy à notre confrère préfère
laisser les commandes aux pilotes
si vous voulez tenter de faire décoller
l'a320 vous pouvez toujours venir
essayer
l'exposition est ouverte jusqu'au 21
décembre et l'entrée est libre
elle est une idée de sortie musicale à
présent un chanter noël antilles et vous
est proposée par l'association culture
et tradition d'outre-mer ce samedi 13
décembre à partir de 19 heures à la
salle gauguin de montigny le bretonneux
c'est le groupe alizée 78 qui animera la
soirée
comptez 3 euros pour l'entrée
tous en scène c'est le nom d'un projet
initié par le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines depuis
plusieurs années des danseurs amateurs
participent à la création chorégraphique
d'olivia granville durant quatre
ateliers nous étions présents pour le
premier d'entre eux aurélia de bissy
avec son projet foule olivia grandville
propose une création chorégraphique
d'envergure une performance qui réunira
juin prochain cent cinquante danseurs
amateurs sur la scène nationale de saint
quentin en yvelines
pensé pour un grand groupe foule
emprunte à la rue ses gestes ses rythmes
les plus évidents et les plus mystérieux
un inventaire inventif des possibles
figure d'une foule de danseurs en
mouvement je sais qu'il ya eu des danses
chorales comme ça au début du siècle
sont servis en fait le régime nazi
il ya toujours un petit peu cette idée
là dans un dans une foule que ça peut ça
peuvent riez faire quelque chose
d'inquiétant et c'était ça que j'avais
envie d'interroger en même temps d'une
manière festive et en même temps en
questionnant cette chose-là de qu'est ce
que ça veut dire une foule tiff la même
chose ensemble les mêmes mouvements fait
ensemble mais dont les consignes sont
communiqués au fur et à mesure via des
écouteurs
ainsi chaque participant interprète les
actions j'ai six déplacements grâce à
son smartphone j'ai travaillé sur des
partitions écrites et partitions qui
appartiennent à un mouvement qui est le
lettrisme est en fait ces partitions
composées de consignes comme ça d'action
de pantomime où d'état a exécuté dans
l'instant est en fait en train là dessus
j'ai truc c'était vraiment une manière
de se mettre en mouvement extrêmement
simple puisque le mouvement c'est ce qui
se passe entre une action est la
suivante et que le fait de les
transmettre à l'oreille directement
comme ça il ya une espèce de spontanéité
d'interprétation sur l'instant qui est
très dynamique et qui est ludique et que
je pense les gens ont vraiment plaisir à
faire pendre dubois s'envoler avec une
couverture
c'est surprenant mais je pense que le
résultat dansant sera c'est l'étonnant
voilà c'est une autre façon de
travailler
ce sont un petit peu commandé en général
on a quelque chose de codifier balaci un
peu de l'impro sans être vraiment de
l'impro vu quand nous transmet au moment
présent ce qu'on doit faire
donc c'est complètement nouveau trois
autres week-ends ateliers auront lieu au
cours de l'année en vue d'une
restitution finale et 6 juin prochains
ce week end c'est l'occasion de vous
débarrasser de vos anciens jouets en bus
sera stationné à cet effet samedi à
montigny le bretonneux une récolte
organisé par la raison le réseau stibus
qui ne connaît pas la crise antonia les
jouets s'empilent depuis lundi dans ce
bus de noël
vous pouvez déposer des jouets à
l'attention des associations
une opération lancée par ski bus depuis
déjà 18 ans oui c'est important de
donner pour ce genre de d'associations
et de deux
de dons c'est surtout pour débarrasser
parce que les enfants sont grands et
qu'ils n'ont plus besoin de ce genre de
choses et les petits-enfants n'ont pas
besoin non plus malgré la crise la
générosité semble toujours aussi
présente certaines personnes offrent
même des jouets totalement neuf tous les
ans je me dis oh là là ça ne va pas ça
ne va pas il va pas y avoir assez de
joie et puis tous les ans on en a
toujours autant
donc je vous dirai ça lundi prochain
mais j'espère que je crois que j'ai une
les gens sont généreux de toute façon là
on a eu encore des personnes tout à
l'heure qui nous ont amené des poupées
barbie tout neuf qui venait d'acheter et
qui viennent nous offrir le but de noël
sera stationné samedi devant l'entrée de
l'espace saint quentin
tout de suite la page sports de cette
édition je vous le disais dans les
titres à l'occasion de la première coupe
de france de quidditch
nous avons testé pour vous cette
discipline en plein essor et inspiré de
la saga harry potter
maxime le maine pour les images
et il lui demandait ce que j'ai entre
les gens maintenant c'est un ballet car
nous avons été poursuivis aujourd'hui
mais avant cela les conseils d'un
professionnel
ce que vous allez un petit conseil pour
commencer le coït c'est de ne jamais
oublier qu'on a emballé les joueurs ont
souvent du mal au début à tenir la balle
jean marc et le ballet de l'autre donc
ils vont lâcher de balai pour saisir la
balle de bâle est une parterre
évidemment et donc c'est une émulation
et place maintenant à la pratique avec
mes supers coéquipières on a lu les
harry potter on a vu les films du coup
ça nous a donné envie d'aller voir dans
cette quête à l'air amusant
l'objectif du quidditch marquer un
maximum de buts en lançant le ballon
ap les leçons à fondre les cerceaux de
l'équipe adverse c'est la mission de la
poursuivre
exmar perdu chacun son rôle
il y a aussi les batteurs eux ils ont
les ballons appelé les cognard ils
doivent toucher un maximum de joueurs de
l'équipe adverse a pour les éliminer le
temps dans l'hérault
aussi
il ya aussi le gardien il enfin
l'attrapeur c'est lui qui doit attraper
le soin neuville d'or accrochée dans le
dos d'un des joueurs s'ils y arrivent
son équipe gagne la partie
tout cela bien sûr sans jamais faire
tomber son balcon
ouais super défi bien joué alors ça
s'est passé comment c'est trop bien
ouais ouais on se faisait souvent
touchés par les cognard mais sinon ça
allait super expérience en tout cas aux
fonctionnaires première map alors que je
travaille un petit un bon suivi tout en
vivant sous une adresse un petit peu
tous finalement c'est un sport assez
complet la prochaine fois anthony c'est
toi qui t'y cole sport toujours avec ce
grand rendez-vous des archers du
département et de la région plus de 300
compétiteurs sont attendus lors de ce
concours organisé à guyancourt et
qualificatifs pour les championnats de
france toutes les catégories d'âge sont
représentées
rendez vous tout le week end aux
horaires qui s'affiche tout de suite
place à l'actualité cinéma
et tout de suite les sorties ciné de la
semaine et les avis des spectateurs au
micro d' elodie moi c'est un super film
j'étais tout seul dans la salle j'ai ma
projection privée basée sur les dérives
d'internet les parents que les vols qui
veulent contrôler tout ça et puis
parfois ça finit mal
enfin l'histoire finit bien mais c'est
très très bien c'est un très beau film
la photo est magnifique c'est l'histoire
qui jette un regard assez cru d'ailleurs
sur une actualité assez récente et
l'histoire c'est difficile en fait et on
pense au cje en train de tourner tout
cas dans le nord-mali qu'ont vécu cette
histoire absolument abominable up et je
pense que abderrahman sissoko a vu assez
juste et je salue par ailleurs la
prestation de ma compatriote cathleen
welland d'associer les haïtiens je suis
très satisfait de la fin de ce film
après avoir vu donc les deux premiers je
m'attendais vraiment à une fin comme ça
et
voilà je suis vraiment très satisfait
très content d'avoir vu la trilogie il
était super j'ai vraiment aimé et je me
la mesure qui s'est terminée en fait
c'était le dernier
un épique et notre coup de coeur de la
semaine c'est celui de bertrand pigné
des yeux des âmes d'elsa pardon à
saint-cyr-l'ecole au cinéma les yeux
d'elsa donc pour ces vacances de noël
nous vous avons prévu tout un tas de
petits cadeaux cinématographique alors
évidemment le hobbit que tout le monde
attend mais aussi paddington astérix et
puis tous leurs petits amis qui seront
là pour divertir petits et grands est un
événement un peu particulier pour les
plus petits et leurs familles
le mercredi 17 décembre à 14 heures nous
organisons un ciné goûter animé autour
du programme de deux courts métrages qui
s'appelle les merveilleux conte de la
neige
peut-être que certains d'entre vous
connaissent déjà le bonhomme de neige de
raymond briggs et bien c'est à nouveau
deux histoires de raymond brise qui sont
adaptés pour le plus grand plaisir des
petits
là
et ce 17 décembre donc à 14h à l'issue
de la projection nous organisons un
atelier un petit goûter et puis un
atelier de fabrication de décorations de
noël
évidemment c'est un atelier en nombre
limité il faut réserver et se dépêcher
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous souhaite un
excellent week end